[Music]
so I can lecture about what I want so
I'm gonna lecture about my favorite
player meet no my favorite player as
everybody knows is MV oh right you do
that at home how come people at home
know oh my favorite living player well
that's close it is vaccine vascular Grob
the number-one player in France
currently number ten in the world
although I'm very frustrated because he
should be number eight in the world that
he decided not to beat his last two
opponents and he played sort of quick
draws with lower rated players if he had
beaten either one of them maybe eighth
in the world terrible anyway I like
Maxine wastrel de Graaf for several
reasons one is he plays for win against
higher rated players with white and
black although that's the last two games
he hasn't lost the game since July 2013
sort of like on the way ever mind and he
beats grandmasters pretty convincingly
he has a very interesting opening
repertoire
I think it's shed leash viele although
it's MCH as the first three letters I'll
try you say that okay now he's black
against mvl you can hear me really good
now you've never heard me so well so
what you're saying is mvle never heard
me so well okay efore shot now he was
blazing okay c6 now I must admit mm-hmm
I play the Carroll Khan occasionally I
wouldn't play it against mvl because he
always pushes all his pawns and wins
he does it every game so if he wins
every game I'm gonna play something else
so let's see if he does that this game
he 5 that's what he does and I actually
made a video for chess calm a few weeks
ago on winning with the advance Carroll
Khan for ye and mvl had one of the games
and just does this then he was Bishop to
f5x clam now 30 years ago everybody
played Knight c3 here and 20
years ago they started playing Knight f3
and occasionally MV I'll just pushes all
his pawns
they'll play h4c 4G for f4 so okay
Knight d2 even different ready to push
all this ones at night b3 so this is a
way I've seen shadow off play you're
trying to stop black from playing c5 by
putting the night on b3 and sometimes
black plays c5 that shows you how that
works
Dany plays c5 okay and MVL wins the
piece and black resigned now we'll look
at the next game no that's not what
happened
how did black win back his piece yes
Queen a5 check now if only Sam Shanklin
was here I'm sure he's watching because
Sam won a game this year against it's
very similar position
it wasn't best game of the US
Championships I'm sure you all know it
no nothing against vara Cobian will be
the demon residence next week and var
had won four games in a row and he
played the Carroll Khan and he lost to
the two bishops here white has two
bishops which is more bishops than his
opponent has Laura has one bishop and
white has a little more space because
White has a point on c5 and this is very
similar to the game that Shanklin won
against the Cobian it's not the same but
it's similar pawn structure okay Queenie
forecheck so who wants to play Queen to
c6 anyone no you watch your opponent to
play it yeah so Queen c6 loses the Queen
to Bishop b5 so he played Knight to d7
Bishop to b5 attacking the knight Queen
c7 Knight f3 and White has two bishops
and White's attacking so vos jeux de
Graaf likes to attack castles a6 black
would like to castle but if he castles
King side he's gonna lose his Knight if
he gasps his Queen side he's gonna lose
his King because
take say seven and you'll resign soon so
a six which doesn't really attack the
bishop because the pawn is pinned to the
rook
so if whack ever takes the bishop you'll
lose your rook so MVL develops his other
bishop
now both Knights are attacked so I
really don't recommend castling Knight
to g6 now that Knights not attacked nine
to d4 and men and veal always plays the
most aggressive move and the computers
always like it so it's very much like
tall but less sacrifices are more
accurate and more alive okay it's all
not alive anymore so nvl more alive okay
but this is the way tall would have
played if he was alive aggressive
occasionally sacrifice and put a lot of
pressure on your opponent well I
wouldn't want to be black here because
black can take this pawn on e5 but that
opens the file to his king if he doesn't
take that pawn I'm not sure what active
play that he has White's pieces are all
really active so he did take the pawn
that's pretty scary Knight takes Bishop
rook e1 can't you just what every game
like this easy just and then resigns now
White's threatening rook takes Knight
winning and Bishop takes Knight winning
because all the pieces are pinned and
forked and skewered I guess if you
Castle I could do some tricks like
Bishop takes Knight and rookie 7 wonder
if that works let's see if he casts 'old
now he played f6 what rule of mine does
that break Erik never play f6 I wonder
who won this game so I would have
castled
and I would have lost but at least I
tried okay he played f6 rook takes e5
check that's what you were going to
suggest say yeah good good answer okay
now yeah now black is very safe so the
problem is if you take with a pawn
like over there then Queenie sevens
gonna be made soon like Queen B 4 and
Queen e7 made with advantage so I'm
guessing he didn't take with the pawn
taking with the night C illegal taking
with the Queen looks terrible so I don't
know what he did
I better push this button and find out
who wants to defend with black you can
do it notice how in morphe style all of
whites pieces are attacking and now the
last piece is ready to come into the
game I don't think black castles yet
maybe it but I forgot about it look with
a queen Bishop takes Knight and Bishop
f4 and black has two bishops for a ruck
and blacks getting checkmated and his
King is terrible
and his bad posture and he didn't send
his model mother for a birthday card for
Mother's Day right because her name was
like Chad veal easily I don't know okay
Queenie for f3 because you don't want to
straighten out black's pawn structure
and every grandmaster wants to have
white here two bishops against a ruck
and now that rook is almost trapped or
is trapped yeah where's that rook going
here and the rook on aide is especially
good no ok and here black gave up
because he was embarrassed yeah this
Bishop g7 is pretty crushing ok so that
came he made it look easy
he castled he started attacking moving
his arm forward
his opponent went ah my king okay
that'll teach him to have a name I can't
pronounce then alright 70 move win now
we're not going look at that
okay golf fans pretty good right no he's
lectured here before we who's with a
golf fan lecture I was in China I have a
good excuse see you there you go okay
now this was played in the Olympiad in
2010
I actually know this game how do I know
this game I don't know any games yeah
this is the game where I think mvl
played a novel Oh No golf and played a
novelty like I moved 20 then he resigned
I move 25 so novelty didn't work out
very well
okay envy else white plays d4 now this
may surprise you
most of the super GM's play everything
with white they play Knight f3 I move
one F or d4 then if their opponents
preparing for them they might prepare
the wrong way now in 2008 I was playing
in the US Championship in Tulsa Oklahoma
the mecca of chess and not you know you
guys you the worst audience ever and the
last times was even worse okay so I'm
playing Alexander Shabanov several time
US Champion and Shabanov for the most
part plays efore then he checkmates me
that he'd trash talks about it okay so I
prepared several hours for efore i sat
down at the board he played d4 okay in
the last round of the tournament
I play Gregory Qaeda knov and Gregory
plays d4 I prepared for several hours
and he played efore and I'd use my
eyeshadow off preparation for Qaeda not
as I was like a while you play d4 and I
drew both games but very suspicious so
most strong grandmasters play both moves
now I play d4 every game before I move
just st. Louis for like the last 20
years and then I was like I want to play
e4 because that sounds like it's fun so
I lost all my games it was fun
so now I play e4 n d4 and occasionally I
play Knight f3 or b3 so even I don't
know what I'm gonna plan move one now
mvl who plays efore a 44 even in an
Olympiad against one of the world's best
players plays d4 and still plays 100
moves a theory that's a professional now
golf end plays the Slav and we got this
crazy variation now do you think gelfand
played the crazy move Dietz a c4
or the attempt to play boring with h6
remember its Gelfand eight-six it okay
now
Bishop takes f6 is the boring solid move
white is this much better the ship h4 is
a pawn sacrifice yet so no 80 moves the
theory which one did MV I'll play the
ship h4 which is funny because MV l
usually plays efore on move 1 but he
still knows a lot of theory here not
sure how he knows theory and everything
so they played this crazy line where it
would be nice to know 25 Musa theory
that would help you and all the
sidelines okay and they played a really
long theoretical line which has been
played many times at the Grandmaster
level and still theory and at some point
and all these rules your theory but okay
obviously they both do them all somehow
and at some point I think it was golf
Ian who played the new move yeah here it
is golf and played Knight takes e4 never
been played before and MV I was like ok
Queen takes Queen and castles check you
get out of check came to get X clam
that's the way god of check and now
Bishop f4 exclamation mark now that's a
tough move to make when your opponent's
played a novelty because f2 is hanging
except F choose not hanging because the
bishop on b7 is hanging and you want to
have two bishops in chests now White has
a very strange idea here one you hardly
ever see white wants to take on aged six
and then Queen is aged pawn with an
extra Queen you figure he'd win okay and
that's good plan I like that plan okay
how do you defend against that plan good
plan
well a low-rated player who was afraid
of that plan might play rook h8
defending their H pawn but you don't
want to play rook h8 because then rug d4
and you basically lose your fourth rank
so we have to play aggressively Knight
takes e5 and they trade and he
goes give me the H pawn and let me queen
my H pawn good plan right Knight c5
threatening Knight 2 d 3 check and the
King moves takes on G 2 and he tries to
queen is H pawn so black is a pawn ahead
but if white Queens is H pawn black will
be two pawns ahead except White's gonna
have a queen so so Knight takes F 2
doesn't work because we pin the night we
take the rook and the knight on h1 is
not well placed because we're gonna go
take it so that doesn't work so he
played f5 h 6 with the aforementioned
plan king f 7h with the a4 mentioned
plan of getting a queen so all we
stopped it oh I hate when they do that
b3 now Bishop d4 could be played but
then e 5 so now the knight on d3 isn't
as stable as it should be as we all know
horses should be stable nothing okay so
what's funny is if I take the pawn on c4
then I can Queen that pawn solid ok also
a7 is hanging so I have a pawn on the
7th rank and I'm trying to win all your
other pawns so he played a five question
mark because he was in time trouble why
was he in time trouble I know why I
wasn't even there I know why because
he's Gelfand that he was in time trouble
that's how he rolls golf and plays very
methodically take on c4 and Queen the C
pawn Knight takes F to c5 c6 c7 c8 good
plan right okay rook F 3 cc good plan
and Ric c1 is probably good but he
checked and this thing is if the black
king moves towards the rook we play rook
g7 or g8 you don't want the guy that
play rogue g7 or g8 because then you'll
have to lose your ruck
so he stopped that but see seven so
that's a lot of passed pawns now White's
threatening rook to D AIDS so f4 and he
checked first and the King stayed there
so after Richard here we could take the
H pawn check and yeah you lose a rook if
you take it if you take this pawn I
check and now it says weird it says rook
to d8 although actually constructed D
it's better than my move my move was
ripped to h1 check which I also like a
lot also good Richard G it is I guess
better cuz it's made its mates good you
win two rooks what winning two rooks is
good okay so he played King to f7 worked
to d8 and golfin gave up so mvl is
relentless he just attacks attacks
attacks and in this instance he just
kept pushing his past pawns and it was
shocking if you go back 15 moves like
that pawn was on b2 and that pawn was on
h4 and they just pushes into the seventh
rank and that's because black had other
issues to deal with what was surprising
about that was they're playing 20 Musa
theory and nvl doesn't play d4 all that
often maybe it was special preparation
for golf and knowing the Gulf that would
play this Mosca variation so pretty good
game from mvl which i say a lot okay now
Cara wanna he's one of the world's best
players right in fact you may not know
this fact you definitely don't know it
you might know that I told you four
times today
Cara wanna broke 2,800 feet a because he
won in round one and he wanted around
two of Norway just like I would have
done but I didn't want to go there I was
working here otherwise I would have gone
in Norway okay now Edgar Schein who
should have a zero he has two drawers
and he's rated like you know 100 and
he's 100 years old
so somehow he's drawing all his games
Caruana is winning all his games
now unfortunately Cara Wanda's
reputation in the world is he's a
terrible blitz player that's his
reputation
it may be unfounded however three days
ago not three days ago for you but for
you three days ago there was a blitz
tournament in Norway and Cara wanna lost
an 11 moves to end to Carlsen so if
you're gonna lose an 11 moves you don't
get a good reputation as a blitz player
okay even if you're playing Carlsen now
this game also was less than 20 moves
this was a blitz game played in 2010 MVL
still playing e4 and we have a real
Lopez usually White's not winning in
1213 moves and real Lopez is not usually
especially when blacks 2800 then black
can defend okay and this is all fury and
here black has about seven different
book moves Knight 85 is the old move
Knight b8 is very old this should be
seven he played an IV eight the Breyer
d3 fact this position was seen yesterday
in a game we had in a class between
Spencer fine go black
Justin GM Hall with white and the GM
lost incredible this should be seven
although Justin played a for that game
very early solid so white wants to put
his Knights on f5 g4 get his Queen there
and win okay so he's getting his Knights
in there Bishop to g5 I don't know about
this Bishop f8 move was Bishop f8
actually played that seems crazy can I
just take on f6 kind of move is that
Bishop g5 and this says that black
resigned yeah I agree with that this
looks like blacks getting crushed on f6
so black played e5 too early and didn't
defend his knight on f6 and more
importantly the score this gameis
because nobody he lost in 11 rooms I
never mind so Cara wanna not a good
blitz player but soon to be world
champion
right no maybe see you plays pretty well
yeah okay so that game I don't believe
this score I don't believe it
although maybe right now this game I do
believe because it was against Magnus
Carlsen now I'm not going to show one of
my favourite MVL games because we don't
have five hours for the lecture but
there is a game you could look up
yourself
MV l beat Magnus Carlsen in a slow
tournament game and the game took
exactly 100 moves an MV L had open a NH
files that he kept controlling different
ones and Carlsen would his head back and
forth like in soccer and then and he
ended up losing so that was one of his
great victories this was a blitz game
and this looks very familiar now VL
played Bishop takes c6 we see a lot of
unusual variations and blitz tournaments
rapid tournaments blindfold tournaments
now there's a great tournament ahead
every year which they don't have anymore
called the amber tournament who's heard
of the Amber turn in it okay that is
good okay and in amber
they played 25 minutes chests then they
played 25 minute blindfold chess so some
of those games and some of those
openings were a bit iffy but they
invited the best players in the world so
when they forgot where the pieces were
that was pretty funny because then
you're like wait a minute why is your
Queen hanging with baton 1 ok so and
then in the blindfold and in the 25
minute they would play unusual openings
because you know they weren't playing
rated shafts so they try something new
now the players play the same opening
every game people get bored well this is
a blitz game so we can see something new
ok Queen f6 now Queen f6 is actually
very interesting move it's not played a
lot in slow chests but I think it's
actually pretty good move and it gets
out of the boring Queen straight
variations that we see when black plays
f6 instead d4 takes Bishop g5 queen of
d6
and we see a very unusual position right
away when this looks like black is more
or less equalized so when black plays
Beach when white plays the exchange
variation he's trying to get a pawn
majority he's saying I have four two
three on the Kings side but you're for
two three doesn't matter because you
have double ponds so when we get to the
endgame I'm gonna get a passed pawn I'm
gonna get more space on the Kings side
and you have nothing and players with
black don't seem to mind because they
have a bishop and their Bishop tries to
dominate
so normally White's happy to play an
endgame and why it's also gonna be happy
to get rid of the bishop and he does so
mvl just says I'm better because I have
a majority and your majority doesn't
matter you have doubled pawns and again
obviously my favorite player a living
player but normally he plays for
checkmate but he also wins long end
games when his opponents defend better
and this game goes on and on and on and
he has the slightest of advantages and
it looks like it's one of like playing a
slow tournament and the game would take
six hours it looks like one of those
games because when I play blitz chess
usually it's like I blunder than you
blunder that I blunder than you blunder
and then both of our flags fall then
neither one of us notices it then we
both inject me and then somebody says
stalemate and then somebody watching
cause the flag and he's thrown out but
here it looks like a slow game like
slight advantage for white try to
advance by majority stop the black from
having counter play on the Queen side
repeat whenever possible they finally
mvl advances his majority on the Kings
side and Carlsen does the same on the
Queen side
but as you can see whites majority is
real and black has those doubled pawns
still should be a dried think kicking
the rook out that wasn't very nice well
I like 91 he wants to play Knight to d3
that was a mean move let's see five pawn
could be weak the f5 point could be weak
why could make a queen so if you're
taking notes especially you at home I'm
sure you're taking notes at home when
you're playing mvl don't let him Queen
because then you'll be down a queen
seems like he likes to do that he likes
to get all these past pawns
okay so he sacrificed or blundered upon
and now he's gonna take the h7 pawn and
now he's just losing all the wait a
minute not
and this looks like it's just a draw but
that's why it's a blitz game and blacks
trying to win and probably their flags
both fell here no oh h7 that's mean so
in this position he thought if he took
the pawn and whites looked that part it
would be a draw so he played 94 for the
win or as we also say for the loss yeah
h7 I hate when that happens
so that should have been a draw like the
last I don't know Ted moves
probably black was better but when
you're blitzing out moves that's what
happens what's funny is black has all of
his pieces stopping the age Florin and
he said no no no you can move it here
you go
he didn't listen to my advice when it
nvl wants to Queen his age pawn c2 now
what would you do what should white do
take on c2 then if he takes on h7 then
rook checks yeah I hate when that
happens
okay but now what's the problem we just
move our rook and I stopped your pawn
from queening like Rick h1 then what do
you do what should white do after rook
h1 or Rick h4 Ric h6 rook c8 or I guess
you could also play Knight g6 check in
queen or queen tonight g6 he did this
yeah that's not good yeah that feels
good a queen up okay and here black
resigned so there it looked like white
was pressing white messed it up and then
he won anyway cuz black went too far in
fact one thing I learned about going too
far in the Chicago open this isn't what
you think
the Chicago open let's finished last
week one of the players who tied for
first was st. Louis's own
anyone are you yelling the answer at
home me that I like that answer no don't
tell the IRS I won the Chicago open no
it was priyadarshan and he won the last
round against cadence Ralph so Kayden
won no money and pre darshan 170 500 if
it was the other way around it would
have been Cade morning 7500 are showing
no money however as I learned from my
source of invaluable information
Facebook now it was a article of the
Cade road
preed are should actually offered a draw
about move 20 but kada needed to win to
get his rating up on her so he declined
ended up losing so sort of like in this
game we actually see that a lot
you can repeat but you refused and then
you lose then you like I could have
drawn what did I do
terrible now this is a game MVL Nakamura
in fact I work for chess calm and every
month they have a death match although
that's sort of a misnomer if you know
what I mean because nobody's died yet
not yet and possibly later this year
we'll get these guys to play the death
match because those guys are pretty good
game we actually had laQuan leme play on
Drake and a couple months ago and
they're both top 30 in the world but it
didn't it was really one-sided I'm
drinking won by 15 points not good I
think that was the record so maybe we
can get these guys to play a desk match
you play five minutes and three minutes
in one minute now when I was a kid
blitz chess was five-minute that was
blitz chess nowadays when I show a blitz
game between super grandmasters and
they're playing in a tournament it's
usually 4-minute with a two second
increment or delay or something so now
they have a strain time control okay so
we have a French so you're happy okay
you know this game you don't know a
blitz game in the French mine come on
okay this should be seven sort of a
newer move and we're sort of transposing
into something else
hey somebody in the B's beginners class
that last class said how do we
get rid of that bishop maybe not good
whereas gonna show us how Hey not good
where showed his house as nice to him
that's how you get rid of it age five
that's the Nakamura school of chest
that's exactly what Joe Garnier was
thinking age five
yeah oh yeah I mean it might be a good
move but I'm afraid okay
Nakamura unlike a lot of super GM's is
not afraid in a lot of times I'm
analyzing again with my student and I'm
like why didn't you make this smooth and
they're like I was afraid I'm like of
what like I don't know just afraid okay
so H five I would be afraid to play I
would also be afraid to have white so
age five is scary night age three that
sort of stops g5 okay so H five the
problem is it weakens g5 a lot so you
can't play h6 and f6 is probably going
too far
so 90 h3 it's a retreat which you would
expect from a French player terrible
audience and you know we're really
controlling the g5 square f6 no I said
that's going too far
so pushing all the pawns in front of
your king I don't know about that okay
tanks takes rook to e1 yeah I like that
move yeah I don't know I don't think
blacks King is very safe okay
we could ask Dustin Hoffman but he
wouldn't know either he would just say
his random stuff right and that joke was
over your head I'll give you guys a
break for that okay King f7 that's the
safest marathon man right you what I'm
talking about
no no marathon near the marathon man
actually that's another movie from the
70s yeah okay Bishop f4 yeah and I sort
of like white that rook on a one's not
very good he's gonna double it up and he
does
okay so not because King like she looks
pretty safe now is it time for white to
sacrifice all of his pieces yeah hello
no I haven't seen this game but I'm
guessing Knight g5 check Knight takes c6
is unclear what do you guys think should
white sack all those pieces you white
should sack all of his pieces Oh No but
your play nakamori you might have seen
it
king h1 Wow calm ski would approve okay
now either Knight can go to g1 very
suspicious okay sure
rookie three now he's not sacking all
his pieces he's winning the
old-fashioned way by not setting all his
pieces whoo that's a long move now I
don't like blacks position very much
now the other knights coming into the
game okay and knocking worth thought if
he waited around white would play 93-94
Knight h6 check Knight f4 and eventually
he would lose so time to get counter
play although very risky and and MV I
was like thanks for the pawn that was
nice of you not only black has enough
compensation for a pond or any
compensation for a pond always repeat
good job King h2 that's exactly what you
would have played right John yeah good
answer I assume he wants to play Knight
g2 but I'm guessing and then that h4
Knight f4 pretty patient for a
five-minute game yeah just waiting for
black to give all his pawns away yeah
this is just terrible
so I think almost anyone would resign
here except me
but yeah Nakamura and I don't like to
resign that's the one thing we have in
common in chess we don't like to resign
although I resign a lot more than he
does yeah we don't like to resign okay
and here the game ended but I don't know
how black swag foul White was laughing
too much they forfeited him I don't know
but I would guess Knight f6 check is
white the advantage okay anyway a player
you've never heard of
Maxine of Osceola Grove half of them I'm
right the other half of her dome you see
how he beats Nakamura how he beats other
top players Carlsen etc usually in blitz
he has beaten Carlsen and slow chess and
he hasn't lost a game in 11 months which
is pretty good right you said that a lot
and almost all his opponents rate over
2600 that's pretty good streak the last
11 rating lists his ratings gone up
that's also good and if this video is
like not shown for five or six months
I'll look quite the fool because maybe
he'll lose rating points the next five
list will be like what are you talking
about so right now he's number ten in
the world if the top top top top top
players don't accept their invitation to
the Sinquefield Cup which they will then
he'll be one of the first alternates to
be invited and then we'll see my
favourite player in person he wasn't
saying Louis once he played in a spice
Cup at Webster and he won the tournament
but he wasn't as famous then he was not
number ten in the world he was number
ten in France me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]